I'm very excited for that well now we
got a line going up here we did it
raising the bottom hello reject nation
I'm Greg Alva I'm John Humphrey fine and
this movie is also known as bran and I
am overall a great person say you're a
good guy either Chuck no all right all
right well they're from hit or miss
movies to follow them on social media we
love these two women right here they're
talented and moving knowledgeable women
with power I'm in love with the both of
them it's really quickly Wow it's not
very clean I'm in love with John which
makes it more completely yeah well
there's a lot of human not in love with
you
babies alone you Wow I love L but with
like a dot over here ah like a point
that doesn't have a line going with it
yeah Greg honest trailers alien covenant
have you guys seen alien covenant
yeah mean alien Kevin did you love it
right mama
something I would not say I did me too
well it's good thing honest trailers did
a video about it because I'm sure
they'll say all the right things here we
go here we go man it's hot before people
and yeah it's very attractive
we open don't really works out place
there is that off of the Orange Bowl
true things argument awesome losers
I got a watch on a lot of fun I did
nothing let me participate you decided
to worry I know how are the earnings
holding from Ridley Scott one of the
best directors working today and also
one of the wounded and the franchise
that makes it official
there are now more bad even moving
founded ones Wow alien covenant watch
out happen Ridley Scott wanted to weigh
about the meaning of life or two hours
he gave us Prometheus now understand the
good old God a Canadian flag that
returns to its side by or roots until it
takes a sharp left turn into the same
white jump territory as the last one
my name is oz 9 years king of changes
look on my wife's mighty I'm span say
the Android poetry for Blade Runner damn
it I want a shorter your girl
any tank job fighting is either Moore
who killed it by sucking it is the
vacuum of space
now that's the alien I remember ah
[Music]
forget about your occurs experience the
chatter where no one stands out
except maybe Kenny Powell and meet the
crew of the Covenant Barry couple so
you'll completely forget or bury until
someone says my wife never know what's
there before behave yourself with my
wife living my wife 6 cheer a gaggle
with idiots are pick up in Taiwan for
the terrible decisions like aborting
their mission because they heard a John
Denver's all since it's a meaningful
chart entry not wearing protection on a
foreign planet with emerging knowledge
will killer aliens and was shooting at
your own two legs
having shower sex in or not acting
within the same blood button twice
trusting a robot who clearly loves
aliens because that same robot told you
to cool
already them characters egg ya know
maybe these are colonists and the earth
is a secret program to deport the
world's biggest morons
forget the humans as you spend most of
your time in freshman philosophy class
with the androids Walter in Texas
Michael Fassbender Jack and Jill set as
both characters playing to slight
variations on a pretentious literature
professor move on Austin and yes why
Shelley who are both so full of
themselves they literally can't keep
their fingers off each other's flu baby
blow did the fingering well yeah Eddie
so he said so much food I did not expect
to associate the Alien franchise with
Luka here we are I will enjoy it for me
I'll do the fingers I screwed it's in
the hands of an orgy notice as you soak
up shot after epic shot while ignoring
and all the tech looks way more based in
its prequel I did it off CGI listen the
prilae see the Xenomorphs move around in
full daylight which just looks wrong
let's see bad medical pieces Mannix
CGI ugly simile River y'all know $32 I
think so that may be feasible
No so enjoy a film that wants you to ask
questions like who are we and why are we
here
have you asking questions like why
should I care why are critical plot
scenes on YouTube ads out in the
movement wait anymore these are making a
baby as this latest in stone gives alien
the same prestige is the Terminator
franchise in that the first two were
classics and it's all been downhill
grenade ah that's the field
starring data and war ridley believe me
she's not almost made it
ah dumb james franco's STD ah and me
right here it's more alien movies are
coming out ha ha ha by whom we use to
[Music]
say this side by flute work since a card
[Music]
such a relaxing thing to do in space
she introduced green Yogi's foot
ah sure really how about that play be
honest rumors done yesterday yeah well
thank you great job yet so let's watch
that thanks for making that that's a lot
of reminders of a lot of things I forgot
about that movie I forgot Billy credit
with his movie forgot everyone does it
you know what really upset me
Billy crowd doesn't die until past like
the hour mark in the movie and they the
trailer show you that Billy cries are
you talking my number of James Franco
cuz James Franco is the one that like
kicks it like wait I don't know he was
in the movie James Franco does like
nothing in the movie but Billy Crudup
he's an important character they show he
dies like
indem in the Train on this show looking
into the egg and the thing on it yeah
but James Franco even like they showed
that point about how they released these
important plot point clips online that
are not featured in the film and James
Franco had a whole like more springtime
in one of those long line clips but he
did in the movie
well that's my only recollection of him
in fact in any of the advertising or
anything is just in that clip they leave
like I remember any trailer or anything
I don't even know he was in the movie
until I thought now like is that [ __ ]
James Franco and this little more
the weird like review weirdest hammy
other super weird makes me depressed to
like watch this and be like yeah I did
suck like it could have been amazing
they had all the elements that they
needed to have and I like I just like I
said that you didn't care about anything
that happened this movie made me angry
much later on after seeing it because I
see like oh they closed all these loops
within the Alien franchise so now all
that mystery is gone that's what we have
room
yeah and they point out something that
always bothers me about prequels when
like everything isn't more is better
yeah things have higher capabilities
than we know they will in the future I'm
always astonished nobody pays that much
attention to them and HP but you guys do
that coming that it was like really the
Walter wasn't Walter but it was actually
David him like vomiting up those things
or whatever he was doing I don't
remember but I was like look it's
happening right now and why yeah watch
this Ostrow time Amy said watching the
movie kind of made me think because it's
one of those like to me it's one of
those faint praise movies where I'm like
if you just isolate it as its own thing
it is fine is a very clean monster movie
oh boy in context is yeah it starts to
rot in your head like the second you
guys I don't hate it I don't hate the
movie
I enjoy it for what it is but at the
same time when you do think about the
bigger like you said contacting your
contact it disappointing for human
definitely does the point I think that
the best honest trailers are the ones
when there's they do it for a good film
right because then you're like laughing
at all the hilarious thing right you
didn't really pick up on when you were
watching it but she both on-screen
shockers having here we have you found
TV fights you were all moving like I'm
yeah now that I'm laying back on Keaney
bites noise - I was on movie fights like
two years ago then I was never invited
back all that for really fight all right
oh whoa well John I don't have respect
and it doesn't matter how big the
following gets we are just talentless
people according to everyone what we did
out in the comments yeah we just see
them a lot of like parties or like
events or I just show up to screen John
use all security guard why no scare you
oh well you're too hot women who know
movies they need that screen junkies man
ever my entire movie blogosphere well
guys thanks for being here
you can subscriber the real rejects
subscribers screen junkies while you're
at it these - I'm not free on Twitter
and Instagram
- more importantly don't give a [ __ ]
about our channel all we care about is
that you subscribe to hit or miss movies
go subscribe to their channel follow
them on social media
literally we could care less if you
follow us that's reverse psychology
right if I know we're doing this Mike I
am that's sorry